[Music]
hi everyone welcome to the longest
session title that you'll probably see
it Google cloud next we tried to see how
far we could wrap arounds but really
this is a much shorter title Multi
cluster manager the cheeky on-prem we
had to keep it a little bit hidden until
the day 1 announcements but now that
we've talked about cheeky on-prem we're
gonna do a little deep dive today show
you guys what we have and give you some
more information on what we've built out
so quick intros my name is Weston
Hutchins product manager on the gke team
software engineer and akkadian ok so
I've got a little story so I'm gonna sit
down oh we started this demo by wheeling
our entire rack from backstage out here
and we're debugging some issues we ran
into a little snafu where we couldn't
get an IP address for the rack so we're
gonna wait on the demo we moved it all
the way back stage again and Akhil is
actively debugging I hope to be able to
show a demo for this we'll try to come
back to it later but right now we're
just gonna jump into slides
nobody said on-prem was easy clearly
we're learning that up on stage here so
I'm gonna start by giving a little
background on our journey to cloud
services platform a little history
lesson here is about we started with
mainframes we started with big boxes and
every evolution since then has been
trying to move further and further up
the stack so Along Came virtual machines
with the which abstract away the
hardware and allowed you to spin up
multiple machines on the same host and
then containers came into popularity now
containers have actually been around for
quite some time Google has been working
with containers for over 15 years but we
didn't really start to see widespread
adoption until docker around 20 to 13
when docker unveiled their stack for a
lightweight container runtime with great
packaging portability and deployment
semantics around
these environments where you could
really package up your application it's
the dependencies and move it from host
to host that's where we started to see
containers actually becoming a reality
but of course docker solved the problem
of taking an app and it's dependencies
and deploying onto a single host that
was never going to be the end journey we
always needed something a little bit
more and this was around the time that
the team started to think about
kubernetes so how do you take not just a
single container on a single host how do
you take multiple containers across
multiple hosts and orchestrate that over
a fleet of virtual machines so Google
started to take all of the lessons we've
learned from our internal container
management system Borg externalize those
with kubernetes but as were said in the
day one key note kubernetes was also
never the the end state it really is
that consistency layer between
infrastructure and then higher level
services it allows the operators to
think about what's provisioned
underneath and allows the developers to
just worry about having consistent
tooling between the two and a lot of the
announcements that you guys have seen at
GCP cloud next have been focused on
these higher-level services so we talked
about K native in the keynote this
morning which offers service and some
pass level functionality that can run on
top of kubernetes we announced STO 1.0
GA which is the service mesh
capabilities to actually think not just
about kubernetes deployments but how
services connect and talk to each other
along with how you can control
connections between those with security
and everything else and then there's not
tools that just Google has but like the
community has built in the open source
as well so we have CI CD tools we have
monitoring and logging agents like
Prometheus we have things like the open
service broker where we actually can
connect to services running on cloud
using an open API and our customers came
to us they said what we want you guys we
love these open source technologies but
we want you guys to manage it for us and
this is where we started offering hosted
versions of all of these solutions so
kubernetes became google kubernetes
engine our hosted managed offering run
that on top of our infrastructure stack
and a lot of the announcements today
came
for like serverless 4g ke and sto for
gke these are managed offerings that we
want to install inside your kubernetes
cluster so that you can think about the
important thing which is application
development and not having to manage
infrastructure but of course just like
one host on a container wasn't enough
and we needed kubernetes we're now
entering the realm of multi cluster
management so one cluster is not enough
we have to be able to spread across
different clusters potentially in
different environments and this is where
Mattan team have been doing a ton of
thinking around what are the tools and
processes in place that people can use
to manage multiple clusters so single
pane of glass UI policy syncing between
clusters CI CD service discovery and
even some demos that were shown off
today of doing multi cluster ingress
using global load balancer and
federating out to multiple clusters but
the big announcement that we talked
about it was really saying okay if we
can do this on gke
can we do it across environments and
this is where the idea is for GK on-prem
started to come into play we said
customers said we want those management
capabilities of G ke and all of the
service layers on top of that and we
want you to run it in our data center
and so this is what we've been working
on for quite some time and trying to
really flesh out the products and the
vision of how we can take all of the
bits and experience we've done with G ke
and move that into a non-prime
experience and most of the announcements
on day 1 and day 2 were focused on this
whole family of products that we've
called cloud services platform that
includes more than just kubernetes it
includes all of the tools that sit on
top of kubernetes as well and with that
that's gonna go into a little bit more
of a deep dive on what it means to do
multi cluster management yeah so let's
take a quick step back and discuss kind
of what we're seeing as far as why
people need multiple clusters in the
real world it is many many reasons so
the first one we see a lot is I need to
provide low latency services so I've got
customers in all over the globe and i'ii
be able to serve them very
with low latency very quickly from
wherever the closest cluster is to them
you can do this today with the Google
cloud load balancer we have a tool that
we built called cube MCI and we're
working on some other tools as well to
allow you to do this in addition to that
people often say you know what I really
want to have highly available services
run across regions so if I have an
outage and say US central I want my
traffic to fail over to the next closest
region this is something again that you
can leverage Google's network to do and
it's something that cube MCI and MCI
Multi cluster ingress in general support
in addition we often see that customers
have this data locality issue so if I've
got a customer that's traveling from an
end-user traveling from one location to
another location I need to serve them
traffic there's traffic to the cluster
that actually has their data that's
another important use case the other one
we see a lot in this is more on the on
the developer side is I need to separate
my teams or maybe my tenants or maybe I
want to have different environments for
dev staging and project and when you
want to do that you necessarily need
multiple clusters the other one we see
is if you want to minute implement a
multi cloud or we'll get into hybrid in
a second but a multi cloud strategy you
also wanted to use multiple clusters
nobody as far as I know really has a
kubernetes a distribution that can span
multiple providers and still be reliable
and finally we often see that that
customers want to try a new version of
kubernetes safely and they'll try to do
it via canarian clusters and so they'll
actually deploy the same workload on a
new cluster a new version of kubernetes
and then they want to transition their
workloads over from one cluster to
another so that's why people would want
to use multiple clusters but what about
hybrid so the cloud we've to sermon must
collaborate with your on-prem and that's
that's exactly why we're building GK on
Prem we see a lot where you've got
legacy dependencies on-premises you
might have an old database that really
can't move to the cloud you might have
some services running there that
really need to stay on Prem for a
variety of regulatory reasons and those
need to stay there and you need to be
able to access them from the cloud
another reason is local execution so you
might want to have a cluster running or
your services running in a warehouse on
a factory floor or in a branch of say a
retail operation and you might want to
use CI CD to push those things out and
actually control the builds the other
one we see a lot is edge computing and
IOT so this is necessarily in a
situation where you don't have great
connectivity and you might have loss of
connectivity to the cloud but you still
want to be or to operate these clusters
on Prem another one is global
availability you know your cloud
provider isn't going to be exactly in
every region you want to be in
potentially and so you can use G K on
pram or just a hybrid in general to
provide services in these locations and
then
closely tied to that as the data
locality so there's a lot of
restrictions on where you can house data
and you might want to have policy that
you can enforce and you can place it in
a specific location and finally once
you're on Prem you know you can take
advantage of a lot of the things that
your cloud provider offers by reaching
out from your on-prem to the cloud and
that then necessarily engaging you
invoke cloud services from on Prem
so as you can see it's pretty clear that
you really need to be a lot of companies
need to be thinking about being both on
Prem and in the cloud you need to be
thinking about many clusters so with
that I'll say you know okay you know
multi cluster and hybrid cloud is a
reality so what it should be easy right
it's not there's a lot of challenges
with this so if I have kind of three
things that I'll discuss your workload
services and environment and the first
one is the workloads and there's a lot
of challenges here so just deployment
and placement is a big challenge you
have technical and business requirements
dictating where you're gonna deploy your
services and your data local
requirements are gonna dictate it as
well
you probably want to have CI CD
integration
any kind of solution you come up with so
that you have best practices around
deployment and then multi cluster
introspection and you know is another
issue how do you ingest all your logs
into one place how do you monitor every
service you've deployed every workload
you've deployed across many environments
services as well is another big
challenge so I discussed this earlier
when I just showed the multi cluster use
cases but performance you know low
latency and geo redundancy that is
something that people often think about
when they're placing services and then
this is again that we're sto and CSP in
general the cloud services platform come
in we've got identity and security so
you can assign identities to your
workloads and you can set up a sex act
access controls across environments and
finally there's the environment compute
is made a lot easier with kubernetes it
provides them abstraction layer above
your cloud provider above your on-prem
environment but just having that isn't
enough I mean kubernetes has many
different versions if you're trying to
be on the cutting edge of you know using
the latest and greatest kubernetes
features you might run into challenges
with the API compatibility a lot of
people run into issues with OS images
and cluster add-ons and so it's not
enough just to say I've got kubernetes
and I'm done and again when we think
about identity and security there's also
user identity and security and access
controls that come into play into play
here how do I ought it say a users
access to a cluster how do we provide
them the necessary access to that
cluster and to that namespace or
whatever it happens to be that they need
to access in there and these are all
things that you know we're going to be
discussing in the next couple or the
next section actually with GK on Prem so
with that I'll kick it back to us I'm
gonna check in with Nikhil how are we
doing
okay well check back in with you in a
second all right so let's talk about GK
on Prem
if you want to go and get started with
kubernetes over there if you want to get
started with kubernetes one of the
biggest challenges is actually getting
the installation and configuration
correct if you go to kubernetes i/o it
usually involves wading through over 40
distributions 60 vendors that are
offering kubernetes solutions and just
choosing the right one can be a task in
and of itself most of the time people
can get clusters up I think the real
challenge that I hear from a lot of
cluster operators is how you actually
manage this long term this is really
where a lot of the pain lies things like
how do you encrypt and backup at CD how
do you do security patches across your
system high availability is something
that we've been working on for a very
long time it's a very complicated piece
of setup where you have to have load
balancers and redundancy separating that
CD across multiple failure domains and
then finally things like managing users
and policies that's also a very big one
when you start to not just think about
the technical bits that make up a
cluster but how you assign quota and
rate limit those out across your
organization almost every customer that
was using gke that had some system on
Prem came to us and they said well what
do you recommend and prior to this week
we kind of said well here are some great
options out there not like Google and
they said but what we really want is gke
but we wanted on Prem we wanted in our
own environment and so that's when the
team started going back and thinking all
right well maybe we can do this let's
start let's start thinking about what it
is this is the the product for gk on
prem our real goal is to try and figure
out how we can bring turnkey
production-grade
easy installation the best parts of the
GK experience to your environment a lot
of the stuff we've been hearing is like
if you can just solve installation and
upgrade we'd be happy we want to make
sure that all of these things are tested
and validated by Google and that we're
constantly applying security patches but
we don't want to just stop at the
kubernetes layer a lot of these stuff
we're working on on our cloud platform
is expanding the capabilities of gke to
offer other higher level services so
things like Google cloud build container
registry we have vulnerability scanning
we have a number of other features
around like audit logging we want to
make these feature
that customers can use for gke and
Google cloud platform also available for
our GK on Prem product and just as I
intro'd cloud services platform is
really sitting on top of this base layer
that is GK on Prem we want to make sure
that we can offer not just kubernetes
but things like service abstractions
things like developer tools and pads
like components that you can use to give
to your developers and that's where Kay
nativist do and some of the marketplace
solutions come in and that kind of
alluded to this we hear a lot of people
say well the most important thing is
really getting consistent it's it's
first off just the tool stack that they
use to provision and upgrade kubernetes
but it's also ensuring that you have
conformant kubernetes that you have the
same add-ons deployed in every cluster
you have the same configuration in every
cluster people really want high
confidence that you can take a work load
and make it portable and the one real
way to do that is ensure that your
environments are consistent no matter
where you're deploying so for
installation configuration the early
focus for us has really been getting on
a VC environment for our alpha which is
going to be available in the fall the
primitives are really trying to come up
with what is that GK experience that we
can offer for the for the early versions
that we have we've been focusing on a
nice CLI installation supporting things
like online and offline insulation
private can private container registry
support for people that are behind
firewalls and I think one of the most
important pieces of this is the
customers that we've been talking to
want to move fast they don't want to
have year long upgrade cycles they see
the pace that would go of which we move
with kubernetes in gke and we want to
help them move at that pace as well so
moving on the latest three versions of
kubernetes and keeping that rolling
window up updated is such a big core
component of what we're trying to offer
and then we want to take some of the
great features that we've been working
on for gke things are on high
availability and like automatic repair
of your nodes to your on-prem
environment so Nikhil I'm gonna check
back in on the demo how are we doing I
can't I just started cluster should we
do that all right I'm gonna kick it over
to Keo who's gonna show you a quick demo
all right so we have gk on Prem which
you can have your own cluster but then
the next step is and really the powerful
step is when you connect it to Google
Cloud console so here I'm showing you a
cloud console and I'm in the clusters
view and you can before now you could
you can list your gke clusters and you
see all the clusters there you can go to
the workloads UI and see your workloads
on gke cluster but now what you'll see
is we have this additional register an
external cluster so what you can do
using this is you can register your
on-prem gke cluster with cloud concern
so let's try that out I'm going to
register external cluster it gives me
two options I can use public internet
connection to register my cluster or I
can use DK connect let's try GK connect
what it's going to do is it'll ask me to
install a connect agent into my cluster
which will which will establish a tunnel
from the cluster to cloud console so
that cloud console can then send request
to the cluster so let's give my cluster
a name I want to give it one Prem
cluster and now I'll download the
manifest which I have to install into my
cluster so let's look at what the
manifest looks like the manifest has a
service account that the agent will use
it has cluster role binding and it has a
deployment this deployment is the agent
that would run that would establish the
tunnel from the cluster to cloud console
so let's go ahead and apply it
you can see it created a service account
cholesterol binding and a deployment and
you can see this is waiting right now
and hopefully fingers crossed if the
demo works it should show us a green
checkmark it works so now this shows
that the agent was able to set up a
connection from the cluster to cloud
console so let's try the next step now
cloud console needs some more
information which is basically the queue
config information for it to be able to
send kubernetes api requests to the
cluster so let's have a let's copy your
queue conflict
as you can see in this case I'm using a
mini Q cluster you could it could be a
GK on-prem cluster it could be a G
seedless your D a cluster you brought up
yourself it could be any kubernetes
cluster as long as you it uses the
kubernetes api so i will go ahead and
authenticate I'll skip authentication
for now just let's see registration
works awesome now we see in this same
clusters list view you have your GK
cluster which is the East Coast and you
also have your on-prem cluster if I stay
if I go to work loads I continue to see
workloads from my East Coast cluster and
ideally I should see workloads from my
this new cluster that I just registered
but since I haven't logged into it I
don't see it so let's try to log into it
I'm sorry I have to type all of this but
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
use I'm going to use the token of the
service account that I just created for
my agent
so I can use basic auth or token in this
case I'm going to use token and voila it
works now you can see workloads from
your East Coast cluster and your on-prem
cluster all in the workloads view if I
go back to my clusters list you'll see
now you can also see total cost total
memory earlier it was all blank now it
can access all this information if I
click on my own print cluster it shows
me even more information this is a v1
dot tent cluster that's running what all
storage information I have what all
nodes I have in this case I've just one
cluster one node which is the mini cube
API server I can go dig deeper so this
now empowers me to use all the cloud
console functionality that I was able to
use with a GK server now I can now use
it with my any other cluster as well
which is great cool thanks to kill we
had that demo working on the RAC earlier
technical snafu but thank you for that
shows it shows not just that we can
offer the GK experience on the box but
we can actually take any kubernetes
cluster and register with our cloud
console gnome so the question I often
get is like what is management mean for
GK on Prem a lot of the stuff that we
want to offer is a Google managed
experience both through tooling but also
through a persistent connection with our
cloud console where we can monitor and
health check and keep things up to date
so part of what we're trying to go out
with is both an option where Google
manages your cluster and also we have
partner supports that can help deploy
these in other environments but even
outside of that we want to provide extra
tooling above and beyond even what we
have for some of the gke stuff so we
want to make sure that we can get the
right metrics out of the cluster that we
have automatic repair and we even offer
some node management features such as a
node auto upgrade and node repair that
we offer as part of our gke on the cloud
experience now logging in monitoring is
a little different in the sense that we
know that a lot of people have to have a
local log mount experience for doing
debugging we don't want to have to
egress everything back to the cloud but
we do know some people want the best of
both world
so what we're offering is a prebuilt in
in cluster dashboard based off of a
prometheus graph on any of k stack and
after you do that you can browse
everything locally you can have the
metrics in your cluster and do some
local debugging you can then install
stackdriver agents and register it with
Google Cloud console and have all of
these metrics ingested into GCP this is
what we demoed at the keynote on day one
where we were actually showing metrics
coming in and showing up on top of the
service graph now the real big power of
this is we want people to use the same
tools to manage both their GK clusters
in the cloud in on-prem so we want
stackdriver to be that place where
people go to set alerts and configure
dashboards so that they can view both
clusters in the same place the best part
is is that stackdriver supports
Prometheus as a datastore under the
covers so there's no extra
instrumentation requirement identity is
an area where we want we're working with
a lot of customers and trying to figure
out how we can meet their needs on Prem
and also move them to the cloud so we
know that Active Directory is going to
be a part of our solution we want to
integrate natively with people's local
Active Directory trees but for every
feature that you need to use in Google
cloud platform we need to have a GCP
identity so we're exploring options
things like Google cloud directory sync
things like provisioning a set of users
for use in our cloud console and all of
the GCP services we'll have more details
about some of the stuff a little bit
later on the other thing that we know
customers are going to want is the
ability to use their own cert authority
in their on-prem cluster so we're going
to support the ability to bring your own
public key infrastructure another part
of CSP that we unveiled at next is
policy management so this is a feature
that allows you to create and define
policies using a declarative
configuration check those in to get as a
source of truth and then federated sync
those across every cluster that you have
whether they're running in the cloud and
on-premise so this allows you to do
things like set up how you want your
users to access all of the clusters and
then manage them centrally through
Google Cloud console and the policy
management syncing tools there's
a bunch more depth that's gonna be
covered at a session tomorrow with Ray
Kalina and John Murray in that Thursday
at 11:45 in Moscone West if you want to
hear more about this cool new feature
and then Nikhil was saying before we
really want Pantheon to be the place
there sorry
cloud console to be the place that
people come in and manage all of their
workloads and manage all of their
clusters from a single pane of glass UI
GK on Prem is special this is a google
managed kubernetes offering and that's
gonna register seamlessly with Google
Cloud console but there will also have
the ability to take any kubernetes
cluster whether they're running on mini
cube locally or even in another cloud
provider and register it with our single
pane of glass solution which is what we
demoed so we're gonna skip that part of
it right now and Matt is going to tell
you a little bit more about the gke
connect agents there we go all right so
we quickly showed you a demo of us
connecting from mini cube back to GCP
and I wanted to do a quick dive into
what we actually did so Nikhil mentioned
we installed this connection agent onto
the cluster and what this is it's just a
deployment that dials out from google
fruit sorry from the cluster to Google
and creates a long live connection once
we have that connection in place this in
we have the ability then to to go back
through the connection the other way and
provide you this single pane of glass
experience so when an end-user comes in
and they talk to the cloud console they
are requests to view workload on the
cluster will route through that
connection back through the agent and
ultimately to the API server the reason
we did this is probably obvious but if
it's not then I'll do a quick
explanation here so one is we don't
normally want people to have to expose
their clusters to the public internet if
they're running on creme and
by having this agent reach out from
their on-prem environment or your other
cloud provider environment to Google
cloud we can create an encrypted
connection back to GCP and it can
traverse Nats and firewalls or sorry you
egress firewalls we have proxy support
and we can create that long live
connection and provide kind of a secure
way to to access your cluster remotely
the nice part about this also is because
we are passing the end users so you saw
that the page nikhil showed when we went
to log into the cluster we want every
user to log in with their own
credentials and the reason we want to do
that is we want your audit logs in your
cluster to show a good audit trail of
what's happening in that cluster so when
the first person the administrator
registers the cluster all that happens
is it shows up for everybody and
everybody who has to come in and log in
separately and if the user end user
credentials like I said we're gonna have
really good audit logs that end up in
the cluster so it makes auditing really
really good so Wes mentioned also that
that this doesn't extend to just GK on
Prem or other GK clusters it really
expensive
bring your own coober nice clusters and
once we have that agent installed we can
do a lot of things so we mentioned the
single pane of glass but we're looking
at at integrating with a lot of other
services including the marketplace and
stackdriver and a bunch of other things
to provide the GK experience really for
a lot of clusters that aren't even from
GK and with that we'll wrap it up
there's a couple of things here I'll
note so one is that GK on Prem uber
Cuvaison friend is going to be available
in alpha this fall and also that we have
a sign-up form I think we're missing the
link so we'll put that up right before
we wrap but that's pretty much it so
we'll take questions offstage and thank
you very much for coming
[Music]